onze candidats sur la ligne de départ
pour cette élection législative
partielle c'est le 20 septembre prochain
pour le premier tour dans la 11e
circonscription des yvelines éventuel
deuxième tour le 27 septembre une
élection rendue nécessaire après la
démission de nadia qui est devenu
ministre délégué à la ville
et parmi ces onze candidats jérémy
blizzard est avec moi en visio bonsoir
vous êtes le candidat de france écologie
pour ce scrutin vice président de cette
formation politique vous n'en n'êtes pas
à votre première campagne puisque vous
étiez présent sur une liste candidate
cerner la ville lors des dernières
municipales vous avez été également
candidat en 2017
lors de l'élection législative dans la
2e circonscription vous avez vous aviez
recueilli 1,29 pour cent des voix
candidat également en 2012 dans la 11e
circonscription avec un résultat de -2
1% des voix pourquoi cette nouvelle
candidature et pourquoi cette fois ci
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
tout d'abord pour qu'il y ait une
candidature écologiste qui puisse
rassembler l'ensemble des citoyens des
électeurs qui souhaitent exprimer pour
une créature écologistes en 100% une
créature qui va au delà des clivages
habituels droite gauche dans laquelle
souvent sans faire de l'écologie pour
qu'on ne soit pas des faire valoir d'un
programme
mais qu'on soit un programme écologiste
pas que sur l'environnement aussi sur
l'éducation la santé la culture sur
l'ensemble des thématiques qu'on puisse
avoir un vrai projet écologiste à l'aube
ce que si on parle d'un autre parti
europe ecologie les verts ce parti
soutient une autre candidature celle de
sandrine grand grand homme il faut
davantage parler d'écologie vous le dit
c'est pas la sphère de clivages
politiques
et ça absolument je pense qu'aujourd'hui
clivage droite gauche comme on
l'entendait il y avoir pas longtemps n'a
plus vraiment de sens aujourd'hui la
question écologiste a repris au coeur de
beaucoup de citoyens et dépasse les
clivages et des gens de droite de gauche
qui ne se reconnaissent d'ailleurs ni
ange ni de droite ni de gauche
qui sont écologistes et je veux par ses
créateurs porter un discours qui puisse
les rassembler tout ce n'est pas d'hier
langue ou de droite donc logique mais on
a vu que cette thématique était centrale
dans les dernières municipales est ce
qu'elle est devenue davantage la crise
sanitaire et ce qu'elle a fait prendre
aussi conscience à votre avis de tout
l'enjeu climatique aussi puisque on a vu
pendant cette crise sanitaire et pendant
le confinement que les choses pouvaient
s'améliorer avec de petits gestes au
quotidien
absolument je pense que la crise qu'on
vient de vivre qui n'est malheureusement
pas terminé a permis à beaucoup de gens
de retrouver la proximité vous pouvez
plus allé loin on est obligé d'aller
dans les mains timide et dans des chais
romande et dans des boucheries vendée
creamer et on a retrouvé ce goût du
local et surtout ce bout de la qualité
et je pense qu'il serait dommage fin de
cette crise qu'on reprenne les mêmes
études qu'avant la campagne municipale a
effectivement donné pas mal de voix aux
écologistes rassemblés ou pas je pense à
certaines listes de la france à nice où
il ya une liste qui a recoupé je pense
100% des partis politiques et d'autres
listes et qui est un des meilleurs
résultats en france liste écologiste il
ya la preuve que quand on se rassemble
on est capable de porter haut et fort
les couleurs écologistes a besoin d'être
à faire valoir notre parti pour cette
édition initiative malheureusement mais
voilà je pense que les citoyens les
électeurs ont vraiment envie de pouvoir
exprimer une volonté écologistes au delà
des clivages
alors les idées que vous avez envie de
porter vous en avez parlé celle du
circuit court les commerces de proximité
sont des choses que vous avez envie de
porter de de mettre en avant si vous
êtes d'avant d'aventuré lui à
l'assemblée nationale d'autant plus que
là le mandat sera très court c'est une
élection partielle
donc on aura compris un an et demi de
mandat je pense qu'en un an et demi il
faut au delà des grands discours des
grandes thématiques le projet sur v
plusieurs années il faut vraiment
essayer de la portée des idées concrètes
pour un an et demi n'y ait effectivement
essayé de promouvoir la grille
l'agriculture biologique les commerces
de proximité et circuits courts et
comment on peut le faire
la fiscalité par exemple à ce qu'on
pourrait pas baisser la tva sur les
produits qui sont bio locaux avoir été
la plus faible pour les produits locaux
encourager notre artisanat nous les
décollages de proximité ces gens qui
travaillent qui sont à fond pour l'heure
leur métier qui sont passionnés les
aider face aux géants de
l'agroalimentaire dans l'agroalimentaire
et de tout ce circuit qui les étouffe et
qui souvent n'est en fait sur un mot
rapide juste pour terminer sur la
manière de mener campagne on sait que
c'est un contexte particulier avec cette
crise sanitaire comment aller à la
rencontre des électeurs malgré ces ce
contexte ce sera compliqué ça c'est sûr
déjà la campagne est très courte mais
informé à cette date de l'élection
je pense que la meilleure manière de
faire campagne pour rencontrer leurs
cessera soirée marché faire du
porte-à-porte aller à la rencontre des
gens dans les commerces où on n'a pas
trop de place si l'on doit être limité
je pense que c'est pas une bonne idée
[Musique]
les électeurs là avance le pense
essentiellement se baser sur les
documents qui brossent voir et ce sont
les médias qui pour utiliser les
programmes des candidats ont ce
malheureusement de peu l'occasion
pendant cette campagne de voir les gens
surtout pas car on est tous en activité
pour les gens comme moi qui travaille
son activité donc c'est pas forcément
simple en semaine d'aller sur le terrain
merci
du temps déjà merci jérémy bizet d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
le candidat de france écologie pour
cette élection législative partielle
dans la 12e circonscription des yvelines
premier tour le dimanche 20 septembre